hariri se presenta como la última
oportunidad para sacar al país del
agujero en el que se encuentra tanto
político como económico y social y que
ha conducido a los libaneses a una
desesperanza total sobre todo los
jóvenes que han empezado a emigrar
porque ven que no tienen futuro en el
país
hariri que por tercera vez será primer
ministro se le ha encomendado la difícil
misión de formar gobierno un gobierno
que tiene que ser independiente como
exige la comunidad internacional y el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón para
poder recibir las ayudas internacionales
y rescatar al país de la profunda crisis
económica y también para la construcción
del centro de beirut que fue devastado
por la explosión en el puerto del 4 de
agosto pero una vez más los intereses
personales y las rivalidades políticas y
sectarias impiden dar un paso hacia
adelante y este impase para lo único que
sirve es para que los libaneses sigan
cada día más empobrecidos